I grew up here in Portland.
As a child, we all love Indiana Jones.
But it was actually really in high school
when I was able to take an anthropology
class and it really piqued my interest.
And then in community college,
I started taking archeology classes.
The coast is not forgiving
to the artifacts that we're finding.
They're often broken up
small chunks of what we would find.
Even though we've got only fragments,
they can really tell us
where they were made, when
and even who for.
The first thing you notice
about these blue color designs
is that they are Chinese.
So why are Chinese porcelains
being brought to Oregon?
We found the shards were from large
plates and cups matching
European desire for large meals
in months of hot chocolate.
This is likely a cup, we
don't really know what the foot rim was
meant to be or what the purpose of it is.
But apparently it was a very big thing
with the European market at the time.
Using all this data together,
we have come to a date of 1690
and what's intriguing
is that it's 120 years
before any Europeans arrived in Oregon.
That beach on that side, there's
a lot of porcelain that seems to be right.
So basically what you're seeing
is material like directly
on the opposite side of the
where we currently are.
Yeah.
And you've recovered some porcelain.
Yeah. Just north of here.
Lots of it. Yeah.
So, you know,
you go here to there to there.
It kind of lines up, you know.
This is an underwater environment known
by local fishermen
as a place where they've hung nets.
And that's always a great indication of
of a place
that could be parts of a shipwreck.
Are we clear?
That's perfect.
Okay.
We're looking at the data
as it's being collected
and nothing was obviously sticking out.
I should have more coffee this morning.
And suddenly we saw this one area where
there was this linear feature.
It looked almost like the spines
on the back of a stegosaurus.
There's definitely something out here.
We're starting to pick up already
some linear features in an otherwise
sandy environment.
Yeah, that doesn't really look like rock.
Well, here already.
Yeah. Here we’re
starting to pick up and see more of this.
Yeah, it is four or five meters long,
something like that.
Maybe that's the broken mast.
Yeah, look, it's
got a hollow shadow in the middle.
There’s a whole notch out in this.
This is really where we see it in.
Oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Look at that.
Look at it up here in the...
Wow look at the bow,
you can see the stern.
Look it’s almost like a bow and a stern.
Sometimes X marks the spot.
Could that be the Beeswax?
It could be.